a much anticipated government report on
ufos list 144 known sightings of
unidentified aerial phenomena
now the study released on friday found
only one of those can be explained just
one
the report is a rare example of the
government acknowledging that it has
investigated ufo
cases as david martin reports the lack
of explanation
is fueling even more questions about
what else may be out there
my gosh there is no longer any doubt
unidentified flying objects are wreaked
this one was seen by now retired navy
pilot
alex dietrich in her f-18 off the coast
of california there were
two aircraft in our visual encounter
each aircraft had
two aircrews and then immediately
following that a single aircraft with
two aircrew
who were able to lock onto this
thing and get the clear footage it's
been 17 years
and a new report by the office of the
director of national intelligence
still can't explain that and more than
140 other
sightings of so-called unidentified
aerial phenomena
some of which appear to demonstrate
advanced technology the way that it was
maneuvering the way it was
accelerating and also hovering uh
it seemed to have capabilities that
our systems would not have been able to
display or keep up with so certainly in
that moment
there was some shock at all the report
says there is no evidence these objects
came from outer space and no evidence
they represent a technological
breakthrough by a arrival like china
or russia where they came from and where
they go
remain a mystery but the director of
national intelligence says
they may pose a challenge to u.s
national security
anything that is unknown that's as close
to the coast as
it was i think that's a concern this
object went into the water also off the
coast of california in 2019
the navy could find no wreckage leaving
it next to impossible to determine who
it belonged to
for cbs this morning david martin the
pentagon
so no evidence that they're from outer
space no evidence or a foreign rival but
it's a little concerning when you have a
military aviator saying we saw
this thing we have no idea what it is
and the and that they have
they appear to have advanced technology
i want to see somebody waving
zoom in there is there someone in the
window no klaus on steadicam said i just
and i'm with him i want to see somebody
waving somebody waving
yes in the cockpit yes alien on board
sign
through the window just something